I can't break through that glass first
you see I'm an actor
there's only one Tom Cruise but he's put
his life on the line countless times for
the mission impossible franchise
including many dangerous stunts all
performed by Cruz himself et was there
at the beginning to learn how the
unbelievable scenes came together
always why mission impossible what was
it that triggered your fancy about this
particular idea it just it's asking for
to be made I felt it into a future
family you know you have this half-hour
series on television back in the 60s or
70s and I thought I could just picture
the trailer you know and this story and
I just it's the intrigue
he was just there from you know you
could take it anywhere we you know you
could take it anyplace it's much worse
you think yes you know that was one of
the things I thought was gonna be a lot
of fun in this movie and and Brian
designer sequences I could do my own
stunts you know they have a little fun
with that stuff and Brian designed the
sequences so that I could do pretty much
with 95% of my own stunts and then we've
got to the that sequence I mean tons and
big chunks of glass so I thought you
know I don't think I got to get up break
through the glass hit this mark fire the
one final what about and then go what
would I say look man I said I can't
break through that glass first you see
I'm an actor you know yeah I I will
stand there and do everything in my
power when that first one goes but when
you know he and he just kind of looked
at me you started laughing you can't
understand you very upset Kate Ritchie
you never seen me very upset I'm telling
you I was there and that cameras on me
and it's dark now everyone's on the set
you know there's a bunch of people came
from around to see me get creamed
and they said 1 & 2 that tank blew
behind me I just have to keep saying
myself stay there I mean you could I
could feel the glass hitting the back of
my legs and them you know I had this
coat on the back of my coat I could feel
the water come around thinking three pan
three three where's three where's three
it was like through
and then BAM I hear the thing explode
above me and I just I was gone and there
was just a well I mean it was a wall I
could feel the chunks of glass hitting
Matt I also had to go and jump over a
guy who was out there with the furniture
and everybody else following behind me
yeah it was exciting I I i enjoyed it
yeah I enjoyed it I it was fun
that's great because so often an actor
will say oh well it was really nothing
oh no it was exciting it was exciting
and then the helicopter and the train
and the wind tunnel now I was reading in
the production notes or someplace that
there were a lot of people said Tom you
can't have a hundred and seventy mile an
hour wind tunnel for these days they
were trying took us a while to figure it
out and I finally I skydive so I said
look get flight skydiving simulator
let's get this get it here rig it up and
see what we have
we tried jet engines we tried Ritter's
we tried I mean these guys were months
trying to figure this thing out because
I wanted the distortion on the face you
got a high speed train I didn't want the
wind just blowing my hair and when they
fired that thing up they did a great job
of breaking it because I was hanging on
you were hanging on to that thing you
know it was exciting we felt like you
know a kid up there doing all this stuff
it was great where do you really draw
the line between being wanting to do
something the challenge of it but the
real sense of this could be dangerous
how do you draw the line well it was
dangerous but it was fun and you do
everything you can to make it as safe as
possible but I mean I you could walk
across the street get hit by a car
[Music]